Okay, so welcome back. Welcome back to the
computer screen. What we're going to do
now is we're going to continue building
our knowledge and understanding, continue
building our education in the bond market.
Now, obviously, in the previous video, we
looked at real interest rates and the
yield curve as leading indicators.
indicators to the economy and the stock
market. What we're going to look at now is
another leading indicator. So welcome to
video number five, leading indicators two,
corporate bonds and credit spreads. That's
what we're going to focus on here. We're
going to look at the bond markets in the
corporate world and look at credit spreads
of the corporate bond market over the
benchmark. Now, there's
there is a download that accompanies video
number five. So if you go to the downloads
area under video number five, you will see
the following spreadsheet file. So go to
the downloads area under this video and
download corporate bond indices, the Excel
file corporate bond indices. And that
gives you all of the supporting resources
and data that you need for this
video. So what exactly is a corporate
bond? Well, let's start building up our
knowledge here. In the previous video, we
learned about government or sovereign
bonds. So when a government borrows money
from the private sector. Here, what we're
going to look at are corporate bonds. So
that's when companies borrow money from
the private sector. And we're going to
look at corporate bonds. So that's when
companies borrow money from the private
sector. And we're going to look at
corporate bonds.
look at how we can use corporate bonds.
How we can use them as a tool in aggregate
as leading indicators to predict the
economy and therefore equities. So the S&P
500 predicting returns in the stock market
as a whole.
Now, a corporate bond is just simply debt
issued by a company in order to raise
capital for their business operations and
to grow the business. Corporate debt has
yields like all debt. Okay. Yields on
corporate debt typically trade at a
premium to government debt and benchmarks
because of higher company risk of
decrease.
They work in the cost. They work in the
cost. They work in the cost. They work in
the cost. They work in the cost. They work
in exactly the cost. They work in exactly
the same way as government bonds, except
in this case, the issuer is a corporation
or company itself. Okay.
And the principle is paid back to
investors. So it's all pretty
straightforward stuff to understand the
basics of what a corporate bond actually
is. Where we are going to focus our
attention. Yes, no surprise. We will be
focusing our attention on the United
States.
For corporations inside the United States
and outside the US worldwide and for
international corporations with operations
inside the US and overseas. It is by far
the most important corporate debt market
in the world. And it has a massive impact
on both US and global liquidity and
obviously gross domestic product. For
corporates, debt financing rather than
equity financing is often preferred
because it's a much cheaper way of raising
capital. It doesn't require selling an
equity stake in the company or diluting
current shareholders. And prior to
issuance of any debt, a corporate bond is
basically reviewed for its credit
worthiness by what we call ratings
agencies.
It's actually categorized. So the
categorization of credit worthiness will
pretty much determine the price or level
of interest that a corporate bond is
issued at relative to the risk-free rate,
which we are using as the 10-year treasury
rate. We are using this as our risk-free
rate as our benchmark.
Now, continuing our understanding of
corporate bonds and the corporate bond
market, we need to understand what a
credit spread is. So the corporate bond
market works in a particular way. We have
a primary market and a secondary market.
So once a corporate bond is issued in the
primary market and the company has raised
the market,
the money on the issuance of the money on
the issuance of that debt. So investors
cover the principle. It then trades in an
open secondary market and the price. So
the yield is determined by the private
sector, by the free market. Okay.
Now, there's obviously going to be many
factors that are going to affect the yield
or the premium at which a particular
corporate bond yield trades versus the
benchmark 10-year treasury rate.
So there's going to be general
macroeconomic conditions, which is looking
at it from a top-down perspective.
There's going to obviously be business
performance affecting the yield, the price
on the bond, on the corporate bond. So
that's basically the business performance
of the company itself. So that's coming at
it from a bottom-up perspective.
There's going to be sector situations
affecting the price of that bond as well.
So sector performance. If a particular
sector is under stress, for example, or a
particular sector is performing well,
that's going to affect individual
companies and the price of their debt.
In the secondary market across the entire
sector. And also benchmark rates
themselves and liquidity all play a part
in this. So there's many factors to
consider. Now, similar to government bonds
and the yield curve that we looked at in
the previous video, corporate bonds have a
spread.
So the spread is the premium that the
corporate bond trades at versus the
benchmark. And it's important as an
indicator for determining risk sentiment
or future expectations in the market. So
it can be used as a leading indicator by
traders and portfolio managers to GDP
growth, corporate earnings, and risk
assets.
So it's like the S&P 500. Now we mentioned
previously that before companies issue
debt to the private market. There are
agencies, ratings agencies that assess the
fundamentals of a company, of a business.
And they basically give the debt that
they're issuing.
They give it a credit rating. And there's
various credit agencies globally that we
need to pay attention to. If you look on
the left hand side, you'll see a list of
all the main agencies. But the most
important in the world are Moody's,
Standard & Poor's, S&P, and Fitch. So
these are the main ones that we need to
pay attention to.
And that's what we need to pay attention
to. And that's what we need to pay
attention to. So let's look at.
So the range of the range of the range of
ratings ranges from AAA to triple C. Okay.
And there's two types of grade in these
ratings. There's investment grade and
non-investment grade. So investment grade
is what you're looking at right now on the
screen.
The highest credit is what you're looking
at right now on the screen. And the
highest credit worthiness and the debt in
the corporate bond market that has the
tightest spreads over the benchmark is AAA
rated. These are top-level considered and
rated companies. So the fundamentals are
solid. The debt is given a AAA rating. And
stamped as the highest-rated corporate
debt.
The highest-rated corporate debt in the
world. Okay.
The highest-rated corporate debt is part
of investment grade. Now, BBB. Everything
from AAA down to BBB is still investment
grade.
BBB in itself is still investment grade.
But it has higher spreads over the
benchmark with yields at a premium to AAA.
Now, you can see on the screen when we
look at the various credit ratings
agencies, they use different terminology
across
BBB across the credit worthiness spectrum.
So if you look, for example, at Moody's
investor service, Moody's, and you look in
the second column where we have the
lettering code AA1. Well, AA1 is the same
or considered the same by the market as
when we look at Standard & Poor's AA Plus
and Fitch AA Plus.
If we look across the spectrum, out to
BBB, for example, you can see that Moody's
assign a BAA3 to their lowest level of
investment grade. But Standard & Poor's
and Fitch assign a BBB minus. So you'll
see these pluses and minuses across the
spectrum. You'll see sometimes different
codes denoting
different levels of credit worthiness.
This table should help you out in
identifying the level of credit worthiness
for a particular corporate bond and
ratings agency going forward. But what
we're looking at here is the table for
investment grade. So going forward,
anything that you see that's considered
investment grade is very high credit
worthiness.
We're talking top companies in the world
that have high credit worthiness and good
fundamentals. We're talking top companies
in the world that have high credit
worthiness and good fundamentals according
to the credit ratings agencies. Now
outside of that, we have non-investment
grade. So what we term in the market as
junk bonds.
So what we're talking about is junk bonds.
Now we're talking about junk bonds. Now
you're talking about junk bonds. Now you
often hear this phrase in the market. We
hear in the corporate bond market, the
phrase of high yield debt. Okay. The high
yield market.
Well, the high yield market is pretty much
what you're looking at on the screen here.
It starts at the double B plus level. And
if we look from the left to the right,
you'll see that outside investment grade.
So non-investment grade, junk bond, high
yields. This is where the high yield
corporate bond rating is.
Well, the high yield market is pretty much
what you're looking at on the screen here.
It's a, it starts at the double B plus
level. And if we, if we look from the left
to the right, you'll see that outside
investment grade.
So non-investment grade, junk bond high
yields. This is where the high yield
corporate bond ratings begin. Now we have
our ranges pretty much from triple A to
triple C, but triple C is basically
considered to be the junkiest of the junk.
So triple C and lower. So looking at
triple C on the screen and looking to the
right hand side, triple C or lower is
considered to be the junkiest of the junk
with the highest risk of debt default. So
what are these companies? These are
companies that have, according to the
ratings agencies, terrible fundamentals.
So again, this is all pretty
straightforward stuff to understand to
this stage, but how do we actually use
corporate bonds as a tool, as a leading
indicator for monitoring and forecasting
our expectations or the market's
expectations as well for future GDP growth
and direction of the stock market?
Well, we look at aggregate corporate bond
indices. Now, in the same way that the S&P
500 is calculated by aggregating prices of
US equities. So the top 500 stocks, credit
indices aggregate the yields on the most
widely traded credits.
These indices can be split by operational
sector. So the sectors that the companies
are operating in. So for example, like
financials or industrials. But more
commonly, they are split up by their
credit worthiness or the credit quality,
which are one and the same thing actually.
Credit worthiness is basically credit
quality.
So we've looked at credit worthiness
tables. So we've looked at credit
worthiness tables. And we know that
there's investment grade, there's high
yield or junk as well. So non-investment
grade.
But we also have aggregate corporate bond
indices that fall in between. So they are
termed as crossover credits or crossover
aggregate corporate bond indices. Now,
these aggregate corporate bond indices
often, but not all the time, act as
leading indicators to risk assets like
equities, like equities. Why? Because the
market is pricing the risk. The private
market is pricing the premium at which
these assets are
bonds that make up the aggregate corporate
bond indices. So the holdings of these
indices, the market is pricing that risk.
So we can use these as leading indicators
to the stock market and the stock market.
And to GDP. So let's start having a look
at some of these aggregate corporate bond
indices. Let's see what they look like.
Let's get a better understanding of what
we can use in terms of leading indicators
in the corporate bond market.
Well, what we're looking at here is the
CSIA index, which is basically AA, US
corporate bonds aggregated into an index.
And this is the spread of those bonds over
the 10-year treasury. So we're looking at
the spread over the 10-year treasury.
Now, if we look at the chart of this bond
index, what do we notice here? Well, first
of all, just a few things to take notice
of. We can see where it's trading at the
time of filming this video. You can see on
the bottom right hand corner of the
screen, we've got 0.71%. So 71 basis
points. That means that
this aggregate corporate bond index is
trading at 71 basis points over the
10-year treasury rate. What else do we
notice here? Well, we see that when
there's big moves up in this spread, we
can denote that it's basically around
times of economic stress. So if we look
all the way back, for example,
that's how we look at it, we can look at
that. So if we look at that, we can also
look at that. We can see that it led the
financial crisis in 2008. We can also see,
for example, in 2011, when the spread blew
out, but then the spread came back down.
There was obviously a lot of
intervention in the market, not this
particular market, but in the treasury
market from the Federal Reserve. And that
arguably averted a liquidity crisis. And
then we can see here as well, if we look
at more recent times, in 2020, we can see
the AA corporate bond index spread over
the 10-year rallying
hard very very quickly and then coming
back down back under control because of
massive intervention from the Fed. So what
we're looking at here when we look
at AA is obviously the investment grade
spread over 10-year Treasuries. So if
you look back at your tables for credit
worthiness you'll note that AA is very
high up in the credit worthiness tables
pretty much gold-plated just one down
from AAA in the ratings and we can
actually look at even more aggregate
corporate bond indices in investment grade
we can look at the CSI triple B
index. So this again is investment grade
but it's at the lower end of investment
rate and what we're looking at here is a
mix of triple B or BAA rated bonds
and we're looking at the spread of those
bonds when they're aggregated into an
index over the 10-year Treasury the
risk-free rate and we can even have a
look at a chart of the triple B corporate
bond index over the 10-year Treasury so we
can have we can have a look at that spread
like we looked at the AA and we can see
that it's a very very similar shape we can
see that it can predict potential
times of economic stress and potential
times when liquidity is drying up in the
market but we can also notice something as
well that it trades at a slight premium
so a slight premium to AA so as mentioned
this is at the lower end
of investment grade and you can see the
latest price in the bottom right hand
corner of the screen
one hundred and eight basis points which
if you remember the AA was trading at
seventy-one basis points so it's trading
at a thirty-seven basis point premium and
you would expect it to trade at a premium
but we can keep an eye on these things
and not only look at the spreads over
10-year Treasuries of various investment
grades in
the corporate bond market but we can
compare the different investment grades to
each other and we
can check and keep an eye on the premiums
of for example triple B over a high
investment grade like
double A and we can also look at high
yield and junk debt over investment grade
now there are various
aggregate corporate bond indices for both
investment grade and for junk and high
yield
this is one of the aggregate corporate
bond indices for junk essentially the
triple C
investment grade rating this is the
Barclays Capital Bloomberg triple C
corporate bond index
this and the spread over the 10-year
Treasury so there's various products
there's in fact multiple
and you shouldn't worry that we're using
Bloomberg indices here because I'm going
to give you some publicly
well-known indices that you can have a
look at and you can actually go and get
the data on so if we
look at the chart of the triple C we again
notice uh that it does to a large extent
uh move when there's uh
when there's a liquidity crisis or a big
slowdown in economic growth uh this data
uh only goes back to 2013
uh but you can see here that uh triple C
junk debt the junkiest of the junk uh was
having a difficult time
of it back in uh 2015 uh whether it was a
uh for a small period of time a blowout of
junk debt uh versus
uh other investment grade and against the
uh 10-year Treasury rate uh we also
obviously had a major move
uh for a long period of time during uh
during uh the COVID crisis and the
economic lockdown of 2020.
Also note the price so the latest price
bottom uh right hand corner of the screen
uh 294
basis points so if we compare that to
triple B uh and double A we're basically
looking at
around approximately at the time uh a 200
basis point premium now something else
that you uh may notice
or should have picked up on is the uh the
magnitude of these moves so if you look at
the move back in uh
2014 to 2015 of the low to the high of the
spread you can see that the triple C over
10-year Treasury
spread when it moves it moves a lot okay
it moved from around uh 300 basis points
uh up to seven
so a full 400 basis points there and then
obviously the reverse happens uh when
liquidity comes back into
the market and it took a while to come
back down uh for the spread to come back
down but it did
eventually in 2017 get back to around 300
basis points and you can see for example
in 2020 uh the move
from 300 basis points almost to a thousand
basis points almost to 10 percent okay so
the moves in the
triple c uh spread can be really big um
and there's reason for that if we think
about these companies
the fundamentals are rated the lowest they
are the junkiest of the junk
so they are the most affected and the most
immediately affected as companies their
fundamentals are
immediately affected uh when compared to
uh investment grade fundamentals and uh
they're essentially
the most sensitive so the triple c
corporate bond indices the spreads over
the 10-year uh are very very
important to keep an eye on very often
it's the junk that moves first okay so
uh i mentioned uh earlier uh there's uh
there's publicly available indices uh that
you can have access
to very easily um let's have a look at
those so the first one and by the way all
of these are located
at uh the fred website so you can just go
in and literally google uh the name of
these uh aggregate
corporate bond indices so the first one
we're looking at is the double a so we're
looking at the ice bank
of america double a us corporate index
okay type that into google and you'll find
the page you'll be
able to keep an eye on these things uh for
as long as you like you know and as often
as you like and you
absolutely should so here this subset this
is basically the um what we were looking
at earlier via bloomberg
but a different index but it's referencing
the same credit quality it's referencing
the same corporate
credit quality uh the same bonds uh this
subset is double a it includes all the
securities
within a given investment grade and this
one is the double a rated bonds you can
also access
the lower end of investment grade the
triple b complex so if you just type in to
a search engine type
into google uh the ice bank of america b
of a uh triple b us corporate index uh
this should pop up on the fred
website again this is the uh lower end of
investment grade and this is the uh the
triple b complex
uh additionally if you want to uh keep an
eye on the uh the non-investment grade the
junk so uh the triple c's
uh you can get access to that easily as
well just type that into google uh and
you'll find it on the fred
website uh this is the uh ice bank of
america triple c u.s corporate index uh so
you've got access there to publicly
available instruments uh that you can keep
an eye on the double a's
the triple b's and the triple c's and uh
use these as potential leading indicators
uh leading uh economic
growth and liquidity in the economy and
financial markets so let's put all this
together and try to
understand it a little bit better uh in
terms of aggregate corporate bond index
spreads okay
let's try to understand it a little bit
better the price or cost of money for
corporates is very
important okay it affects the capital
structure of companies so equity and debt
okay it affects the capital
the capital structure of a huge amount of
corporations in the united states and the
rest of the world
if the cost of debt so the yield on this
debt or the spreads of the aggregate
corporate bond
indices are blowing out this feeds
directly to the bottom line of pretty much
all major u.s
and rest of the world corporations when
they're seeking to refinance debt and it
has a huge impact
on both u.s and global gdp growth through
defaults again it has a huge impact on gdp
in the u.s and global gdp and it also has
a big impact on the level of employment in
the economy
now if you remember back to the previous
video we looked at discounted cash flow
analysis do you
remember that formula okay well this is
how it ties together okay so if you
remember that formula where
we had the risk-free rate okay and the
risk-free rate was the denominator in the
fraction that discounted
we have to go back back all expected
future cash flows of the company to a
present value but what happens
when uh a company's debt becomes uh more
expensive so we have a blowout in spreads
uh versus the risk-free rate
well those future cash flows the numerator
those expected future cash flows are going
to be lower
because the cost of their debt has
increased and their future cash flows go
down and that is obviously
assuming uh that all things being equal uh
revenues of the company etc stay the same
so if the cost of the
debt moves relative to everything else and
it moves up by a large amount what happens
the uh the numerator
the expected future cash flows are lower
and then when we discount back at the same
risk-free rate
the present value is going to be lower and
of course the reverse is true if the cost
of a company's debt
decreases significantly all things being
equal the numerator is going to go higher
our expected
level of future cash flows of the company
is going to be higher and then discounting
back that number
creates a higher present value so this is
how it all links together via the
corporate bond market on top of
that we have to consider another dynamic
so in addition all things being equal if
money is just generally
cheaper so we have lower yields in the
corporate bond market what's going to be
happening well market
participants will naturally borrow more of
it and this is expansionary and then also
vice versa when it's
expensive when money is expensive and we
have higher yields they're going to borrow
less of it so it's
contractionary so essentially we have a
compounding set of dynamics so this is why
it's so important
to keep an eye on the corporate bond
market and keep an eye on aggregate
corporate bond indices
and just always have an understanding and
appreciation of what's going on in the
market aggregate corporate
bond indices are a predictor of
expansionary and contractionary economic
conditions and the spreads
over the benchmark of various aggregate
corporate bond indices are also an
indicator of risk when
the market the market the corporate bond
market perceives a higher risk of
contraction in the future
they sell corporate bonds and yields go
higher and this feeds into risk assets
like equities
when the market perceives lower risk so
expansion in the future they buy corporate
bonds and yields go lower
lower this again feeds into risk assets
like equities so when we see stress in the
corporate bond market
and corporate bonds are being sold and
yields going higher we typically see risk
assets like equities
selling off okay and when the market is
buying corporate bonds and yields are
going lower we typically see
this feed through to the equities market
and we see stocks going higher now central
banks absolutely know this
of course again they're not stupid the
federal reserve is not done they see this
they see what we see okay
and this is why they are continually
looking to manipulate the supply of funds
so real interest rates in the market and
they're doing this via setting official
interest rates
or intervening in the bond markets to
affect market breaks this is why corporate
bond indices are a good
leading indicator at times but not always
to equity market valuations the fed is
looking at the same things that we are
now these days it's more of the case uh as
to how quickly the fed reacts
so how quickly they're taking action or
not in setting official rates so by a
conventional monetary policy
or even intervening in the bond markets
via unconventional monetary policy
remember throughout history central banks
and the federal reserve actions
can actually panic markets if they are
outside of expectation of the market they
can panic markets
as much as they can placate markets so you
have to be very careful here there's
obviously no rule book
we live in a dynamic world things can
change and the fed is also watching the
same stuff that we're watching
but the fed can also mismanage
expectations so be careful there is no
rule book just keep an eye on these
things and understand what the bigger
picture dynamics in play actually are now
can retail traders
actually trade aggregate corporate bond
indices what is available to retail
traders well
we saw in the iplt video series when we
looked at uh bond products like etfs they
are extremely
limited in their volatility and they
constitute a very small opportunity set so
they can't really be
be utilized by traders for large amounts
of trade ideas and consistent
profitability but
retail traders can look at various
corporate bond products as
indicators of expansion and contraction
in addition to what we learned in the
previous video
in addition to real rates and the treasury
yield curve and what we've covered in this
video corporate credit spreads
but they could also be used potentially as
turbo hedges to portfolios
or just very short-term directional bets
on economic turning points getting
leverage through options
now we've listed uh some corporate bond
products uh that are tradeable for retail
traders uh at the time of
recording uh if these products are
delisted in the future guys or new
products become available
please do your homework yourself on each
of the products uh just make sure that
they're liquid they're
tradeable and they have an active options
market first up we have the lqd which is
the i shares ibox uh us dollar investment
grade
corporate bond etf this is the biggest and
most liquid product at the time of
recording
uh we've got the vcs h which is the
vanguard short-term investment grade uh
we've got the vcit which is
the vanguard intermediate term investment
grade and the vclt vanguard long-term
investment grade
there's also the hyg which is similar to
the uh triple b baa aggregate index that
we looked at
uh and this is basically uh an index
holding uh everything from c to triple c
so it's similar to
the triple c aggregate index that we
looked at uh and this is basically junk
bonds uh non-investment grade
uh a subset of bonds below investment
grade so in the junk complex uh for
international corporate bonds
in europe japan uk etc just use this video
as a template all the same principles
apply that you've
learned here just use it as a template
tying this all together uh with the stuff
we learned in the
previous video on real interest rates and
the yield curve let's just quickly go over
that again real
interest rates what do they represent the
real price or cost of money they can it
can be used as a
leading indicator for the future
expectations of risk asset values like the
stock market and for traders and
pms to potentially act in the present in
order to benefit from future moves the
yield curve that we
covered in the previous video represents
the market's expectation of short-term
versus long-term risk
in the economy and therefore risk to risk
assets like equities like the s p 500 so
the stock market
and we can use the yield curve as well as
traders and pms to potentially act in the
present to benefit
from future moves in addition in the
current video corporate credit spreads
over the 10-year treasury
benchmark this represents the risk of
default and therefore the market's
expectations of both expansion and
contraction of gdp and the economy as a
whole we need to be on top of these
indicators because we want
to predict gdp we want to predict earnings
and we want to predict the direction and
the magnitude of s p 500
quarterly and annual returns we need to
know which way the wind is blowing knowing
which way the wind is
blowing is blowing is crucial to us it's
crucial to traders why so we can make
money from the moves and
also so we don't get caught out in losing
positions that stand little to no chance
of going in the
direction that we expect because there's
been a change in the macroeconomic
environment the macroeconomic
environment is the big picture guys the
macro is the big picture that affects
everything
so we have to be on top of the macro
picture in generating a macroeconomic view
so we build better portfolios okay we want
to make sure that we're making money out
of these moves
and we want to make sure that we're not
doing anything stupid okay all of this
obviously does come with a
caveat because the fed is on top of this
stuff as well obviously we are trying to
predict
future moves in the markets and using uh
the bond markets as a leading indicator uh
we have to be very
careful where if we think uh the market
the economy is going to go into
contraction and the markets going
down uh that we have to be very careful
that uh we think that the fed is not
looking of course they are
um because of fed actions there is no rule
book here that states what you exactly
have to do or must do
in equities whether that's buying or
selling when you see these indicators move
okay so for example when
you see short-term real rates rising or
falling versus long-term real rates
falling or rising okay
when the yield curve is in transition so
when the yield curve is flattening or
steepening or when credit
spreads are widening or tightening okay
there's no rule book that says exactly
what you have to do
you have to be on top of it and you have
to try and make informed decisions so you
can use these
indicators and your understanding of them
in conjunction with the best practices
that we've learned in the
equities market and what we're going to
learn throughout this video series and
especially
when you see the vix in transition okay
real rates the yield curves and credit
spreads are leading
indicators to economic expansion and
contraction and financial markets risk and
direction so risk assets
expectations and possible fed actions okay
key word possible so we've got to be on
top of it
we've got to manage our expectations but
the caveat is when we're positioning in
the market we have to
understand that things can change very
quickly because the fed can intervene and
take action use these
indicators real rates the yield curve and
credit spreads in conjunction with the vix
now seeing as though
we've just digested a lot of information
over the last two videos in the government
and corporate bond markets
and leading indicators from those markets
let's have a little reminder of what we're
doing here
we are essentially trying to process a
systematic framework and teaching you what
a professional trader
systematic framework actually is okay and
we started out by looking at the macro
picture and looking at a
quantitative process of the macroeconomic
picture that is driving the fundamental
area the fundamental work
that we do when we're generating trade
ideas so what we're doing here is we're
operating at the macro level
and we're attempting to understand from
the macroeconomic picture
which way the wind is blowing and
therefore what bias we are likely to have
in our portfolios okay
a bias being a net long portfolio a net
short portfolio or a neutral portfolio and
if you imagine at any
point in the future what you will have is
you will have a long short or neutral
macro view macro economic view
on the united states and the rest of the
world and globally okay and you will build
portfolios according
to that bias and what we're trying to do
here is use the bond market as indicators
of the future health of the economy which
gives us our bias it gives us a
predisposition whether we want
to be net long net short or neutral and
we're not using the instruments themselves
in the bond market
to express this view what we're doing is
is we're building stock portfolios and
stock portfolios that are affected
by these indicators okay stock portfolios
are obviously affected by gdp so we end up
with our bias predicting gdp using
these indicators whether we want to be
long short or neutral in our portfolios
and then of course we're going
going through the entire pro trader
systematic framework to generate each
individual stock idea within our portfolio
now we obviously have a very long way to
go in the video series we're still just
scratching the surface
here i hope but in terms of a systematic
process or framework and throughout the
video series and we
mentioned this uh earlier uh earlier in
the video series but throughout the video
series we're going to be adding
inputs to each area of the process to each
area of the framework okay the framework
itself in the ptm video series
is adaptable to any market okay and it's
timeless you will still be able to use
this framework 10 years from now
now 25 years from now 25 years from now
it's not going to be a problem in terms of
usefulness okay
what may change in the future is the
inputs but the framework itself is
timeless and it's adaptable to
any market okay at different stages of the
framework you can choose to add your own
processes
your own inputs to each area of the
framework this is absolutely totally
acceptable and we of course
encourage you to do this what we're going
to be doing in the ptm video series is
going over all of
the main ones that you should have in
there if you are add stuff in as long as
it's in the spirit of
increasing your odds of making money then
feel free to add your own inputs and
processes to each area of
the systematic process the professional
trader framework and also after digesting
a lot of information
it's often beneficial uh to remind
ourselves of the itpm principles we have
four principles if you
remember firstly self-sustainability
second work ethic third free information
four working smart not hard okay
self-sustainability self-sustainability
we're giving you the tools so that you
never ever have to rely on
anybody else not even itpm you need to be
a self-starter okay second work ethic do
not be scared of the work
we've been through a couple of videos now
and you've seen an example of the work
that we do
and the work that we expect you to do as a
student of financial markets
once you understand it it's fairly
straightforward your processes when you're
going online when you're
doing your weekly processes they're going
to get quicker the more you practice keep
going the hard
yards on now third free information you
can obviously go out online and get
publicly available information
publicly available data anyone can do this
okay but the interpretation
of that data is way more important than
obviously having some sort of software
subscription or just
being able to get access to it at itpm we
stick to the principle of making money
first
you do not have to pay for further
resources you can see now from the
information that we've looked at
in the last couple of videos all of this
information that you've seen is freely
available
you do not need to ever pay for anything
do not pay for anything at all when you're
starting out okay
make money first and then if it makes
sense to do so and the cost is covered by
a huge
multiple of your profits okay then it may
make sense to do so uh if it's saving you
some time
lastly working smart not hard uh there's
obviously uh a minimum that you have to
work on this per week
but there's also a maximum as well do not
go down rabbit holes do not spend 50 hours
a week looking
at the bond markets you can take a very
simple approach
just take the approach that you accept
that there's a minimum that you have to do
but there's also a
maximum get the best out of the hours that
you put in get the most out of those hours
it's a very obvious
uh statement to make but you've got to
work efficiently work smart not hard okay
guys we've come to the
end of uh video number five uh we've
covered government bond markets we've
covered corporate bond markets
and we've uh basically taken some very
useful information from there and uh
information that
we can use as leading indicators to
economic growth and liquidity let's go
back to the desk for a quick recap
okay guys so welcome back to the desk so
it's all pretty straightforward stuff with
real rates
and the yield curve and corporate bonds
and credit spreads once you understand the
definitions of
everything and the relationships of how
everything works together and what it
means it can all be very
very straightforward so for real interest
rates and the yield curve we are in the
government bond market
we are in the sovereign bond market and
from this market we derive a benchmark our
10-year treasury rate
and we have a term structure around the
benchmark and that is the yield curve now
from that we are gauging
both liquidity and risk sentiment as
leading indicators to stock market
direction and gdp growth direction
now in the corporate world so for
corporations we have aggregate corporate
bond indices
and that is across our various credit
ratings and their spreads is what we
analyze over the 10-year benchmark rate
so this again provides us with leading
indicators to both stock market direction
and gdp growth direction
because we are again but in the corporate
world assessing liquidity and risk
sentiment in the corporate
credit market now there's obviously
multiple excel downloads accompanying
videos four and five and it's uh it's very
important
that you update them regularly and be on
top of them it's really crucial to
building your macro view
as part of the overall trade idea
generation process okay so now we're going
to move on to video number six
we're going to give you an accessory that
you can use in conjunction with your money
market leading indicators
we're now going to look at m2 money supply
now in this video you're also going to get
your first spreadsheet
lesson in the ptm video series from
christopher quill who is the institute's
quantitative research analyst
let's get into the list let's get into the
video and i'll see you back at the desk
after the screen lesson